let's go
we are playing with the black pieces
here
let's um appreciate it guys now i've
been playing the kings indian
almost exclusively but uh in this game i
want to play something a little bit
different
i want to play something a little bit
more solid and i want to show you guys
how to play um
how to play more solidly let's play the
slav let's play the slav
knight c6 the slob is a form of the
queen's gamma declined
where you don't take the pawn instead
you protect it with the c pawn
and now we accept it with d64 this is
one variation of the slop john marthamu
likes this line
now what is the idea essentially the way
to understand it is this
white goes a4 to stop b5 so white's
going to play e3 and he's going to
recapture the pawn we shouldn't try to
cling to that pawn
rather than trying to cling to that pawn
what we should do is develop our pieces
in as free and coordinated fashion as
possible which means let's get the
bishop outside the pawn chain
remember don't go e6 here that bishop
remains inside the pawn chain let's get
it outside the pawn chain
and if we're keenly aware of what white
does where does this bishop belong
noticing by the way which weaknesses
white has created with his last move
where does this bishop belong bingo
and this is theory bishop before
exploiting the weakness created by f4 no
rocket science here we're making natural
developing moves
and now we need to develop this knight
d7 being the only available square
but i like this right it's connecting to
the other knight
this is still theory now the main line
here is queen e2 to prepare e4
let's see if he knows it there's many
many moves here queen v3 also possible
i actually know this line fairly well
use h3 which is
a little bit of an empty move uh no need
for us to modify our strategy we can
complete our development by castling
and he goes 94 that was his idea
he is going to end up taking this bishop
but that's not a problem because he's
wasted
a bunch of moves on the taking of this
bishop now here's an important question
should we leave the bishop on f5 or
should we drop the bishop to g6
there is a very important logical chain
that we need to apply here we actually
should leave the bishop on f5
why you guys might say wait a second
what what are you saying
i can see why you lost to el shawn i'm
talking about nonsense he's going to
take on f5
he's going to ruin your pawn structure
but give this a little bit more thought
um give this a little bit more thought
let's go knight v6 expanding a little
bit
once he takes on f5 and we take back
our pawn on f5 is going to clamp down on
his center it's going to control the e4
square
and we're going to create this very nice
pawn mass on the king side
where each pawn defends its neighbor
we're going to go g6
and the f5 pawn is going to be defended
so essentially it's another form of
clamping down
at the cost of yes slightly ruining our
pawn structure but
ever so slightly just one pair of double
pawns never really hurt
anybody and that is an inconsistent move
because he's actually letting us trade
bishops
and his night gets misplaced so he's
wasting a lot of time here
doing a whole lot of nothing now we
should continue making marginal
improvements to our position the reason
that the slav is not to everyone's
liking
is that even if white plays in mediocre
fashion
black is not going to have an immediate
blow now what is white threatening here
what i don't want to allow is the move
a5 i don't want to let white pushes
pawns a6
and introduce defects in our queen sets
what should we do
yeah we should play a5 because not only
does it stop a5 it cements the bishop on
kind of an outpost it's not really in
the center but
it's a good square now let's think about
what what do we want to do here what
and a lot of people struggle in a
position like this but um
there's no need to struggle because the
default approach in a situation like
this
is to continue making marginal
improvements to your position and
one move that i really like one move
that i really like here the fact
is the queen is undefended we can see
here malcolm i actually love your move
c5 the bishop is on an outpost i know
this move looks a little awkward
but remember his bishop is locked behind
the pawn chain so our pieces in a sense
are more active than his
which means that opening up the position
even a little bit should be in our favor
uh and we're not doing anything dry yeah
okay so he put a knight on up was not a
big deal
now we're going to bring a rook into the
game with rook c8 why are we putting it
on a closed file because i am assuming
that eventually we're probably going to
take on d4 and the file is going to open
up
okay so hopefully everything i'm doing
is making sense
now which piece can we improve further
what should we do here if we look at the
queen
does the queen have a nice place
somewhere toward the center
it actually does yeah we can go c4 here
that would be interesting
we can go knight d5 yeah so we can go
queen d5 we can go 95 let's go queen d5
potentially preparing rook f2d8 we are
increasing our pressure on the center
our opponent is playing very well he's
not doing anything terribly wrong
but i feel like he's starting to slip
and in openings such as the slob you
make these marginal improvements we take
toward the center
right we take toward the center we don't
stick with the c pawn because we want to
maintain pressure on the d4 pawn
speaking of maintaining pressure on the
d4 pawn what should we do now
well one thing that we can take a second
to do
is to take care of our back rank yeah
let's go rook fda first but at some
point
it might be a good idea to play g6 uh
and ensure that our back rank is is not
weak because he has already played h3 i
don't want to give him that unfair
advantage okay so a5
how do i think of a move like this a lot
of people here would just want to move
tonight but wait a minute
what do you what do i notice about this
move what i notice about this move
is that it leaves the b5 knight
undefended
if only we can exploit that and we
combine that with the observation that
that queen on d3
is vulnerable we can go c4 into
intermediate move
exposing the attack on the knight that's
why we put the queen on d5 and if he
takes
our knight from b6 evades capture and
takes d4 intercepting
white's queen's control of the knight
he's his knight is going to be in big
trouble here he needs to respond very
carefully
to avoid losing a piece
he needs to be very careful to avoid
losing he does have a way to do that
let's see if he finds it
he's still going to be in quite a bit of
trouble if he does that but
um let's see
yeah this is a a pretty sexy move
uh the album is pretty decent actually
doesn't get enough love i think
it's a pretty good opening for certain
players okay so he hasn't found the best
move
and now we can take the knight he takes
r knight and here it's very important to
be patient
don't just grab the pawn try to find the
best intermediate move
first how can we malcolm tucker is
absolutely right of course
this is kind of a no-brainer we could
have also taken the pawn but then we
would have had triple pawns on the
people now we can take p6
we are up upon and we're basically
winning here now we just need to show
good technique
let's not forget to take care of our
back rank particularly since he's going
to double
i don't want to have to deal with this
crap at some point in the future
what's going to be our plan here well
what i'm annoyed by is this rook so what
we're going to do here and first of all
this knight
and this knight wants to swing to d3
that's a very good move actually very
good move
so let's get our queen somewhere
civilized
and how should we defend the spawn we
have to move knight to d5
if he goes e4 he weakens the d4 square
that's going to be fatal for him
and um what he should do is go rook
halfway one that requires a lot of
maturity though
that requires a lot of maturity
let's see if he doesn't i'm a little bit
low on time so if he goes through cafe
one
uh this is actually not quite as easy to
win as i had initially anticipated he's
done a very good job defending this so
far
but um maturity not in like the
behavioral sense although that too
and he does it i'm going to go rook c7
in order to protect the seventh rank i
anticipate okay
so should we trade rooks should we trade
rooks
absolutely we should you guys are making
the same mistake that i
described right it's not like a test
question where
you're like okay this guy this stupid
guy thinks this
is he rights and the answer is always no
i'm asking you
not from that perspective let's go b5 to
chase the rook away and now what is our
plan going to be here
i want somebody to describe the plan to
me and to tell me how to accomplish this
plan
quickly our plan should be
simplified which means to trade off the
second pair of rooks
and we should do that in the interest of
time i'm going to start moving by going
queen b6
and now we're going to go rook a7 why
are we trading the other pair of rooks
because
once the rooks are gone from the board
it's going to be a lot easier for us to
exploit
that past pawn and now we're going to do
that by trying to dislodge the queen
from uh c2 we're gonna go queen to b2
and instead of going c2 we're gonna
first take on f2
i'll delve into the reasons behind this
after the game given that i'm a little
low on time
i do want to play a little bit faster
here and i will
worry not i will explain everything
after the game
basically i'm i'm eliminating uh issues
so now we can go 94
and if he takes the knight that's
actually kind of a sexy move
uh we go c2 and
the knight cannot stop the pawn
and he resigns good game okay
uh that was a very that was a very good
game i mean he
he did not fold over easily and
this is the reason why the slav is an
acquired
taste because as you guys could see
even if white was playing kind of in
meteor profession
we were very solid but it's hard for
black to win the game in one fell swoop
very hard for black to win like the game
immediately if you know what i'm saying
okay okay so the slot
so basically dc the other move in this
position is to play e6 by the way this
is called the semi-slav
and this creates like the pawn triangle
i think it's also called the triangle
system
and um the drawback of this is that it
it blocks in the bishop on c8 but this
leads to some very very complex lines
like d takes c4 is simpler
and if white goes e4 then black goes b5
it's the it's
hard to recover the pawn that's why a4
is played in these positions
um so bishop f5 e3
e6 bishop takes c4 now bishop b4 i
explained these moves right we developed
the bishop to the square
that has been weakened by his move a4
knight bd7 h3 we castle
knight h4 and now knight b6 so bishop d3
was
poor he should have gone bishop b3 and
stuck to his plan
so just to recap um the fact of the
matter is what are the drawbacks of this
move there are two the first is we
obviously double our pawns and second of
all we do
you know his bishop gets a little bit
more active
but on the flip side our pawn exerts
tremendous control over the e4 square
and in combination with the knight on t5
we could potentially really clamp down
on him by putting our knights on these
two squares
i hope that makes sense and also we can
defend the pawn by playing g6
that's going to be generally speaking
black's main play does that make sense
i know that's not bad so he goes bishop
d3
um no i don't think you should trade
bishops now we go a5 to samantha bishop
uh spicy brings his knight back and now
c5 opening up the center why do we open
it up because our pieces are more active
than our opponent's pieces
okay knight b5 rook c8 so basically
okay bishop d2 a lot of people here
would trade the bishop uh
and you know that's a that's an instinct
that people just have to remove right
because
it's not a good idea to trade the bishop
that's on an outpost for
a bishop that's on d2 that's like
voluntarily
you know getting your dental filling
removed like that bishop on before an
outpost also functions
to uphold the weaknesses behind it right
in a certain sense you can think of it
as
you know it's like the taybridge
collapse you know one of my
favorite gruesome will not favor that's
the wrong word um a very gruesome
historical event
the collapse of the tay bridge it's a
very interesting story
in scotland in the 1870s um
there was an architect i think his name
was thomas buff
and a scottish i think this was edible
or glasgow i don't remember one of the
scottish cities
they wanted to build a bridge the tay
bridge they wanted it to be good
so they come to dr buff
and let me let me actually get the name
straight one sec
i think it's like bowser or something
dundee dundee scotland
so let me get the name straight because
i hate making stuff
up so basically yeah so sir thomas
bausch
so they they come to sir thomas belch
and they commissioned him to to build
the
bridge um that carries trains across the
firth of tay
between the city of dundee in a suburb
they wanted it to be good and he works
on it and they build the bridge
and then on um
28th of december 1879 there's a fierce
storm
that happens in dundee very fierce storm
huge wind
but the trains still run and tragically
because this guy slacked off
and this guy didn't do his homework uh
there were certain architectural defects
that he knew about
and the bridge collapsed while it had a
train on it literally
like the top half of the bridge
collapsed and the train went right into
the water
and uh this was a pretty famous
historical event let's just say that guy
did not have a good
time and there's a famous photograph
that was taken
after the collapse um it was a very
famous photo that was taken after the
collapse
of the tay bridge which looks like this
you can see that just like half of it is
gone
and that's where the train collapses the
water this is like 1870s
um and uh yeah the people unfortunately
perished
so not to use that as a tool to
explain the speed run but to use that as
a tool to explain the speed run
think of the bishop on before as the tay
bridge if you take on d2
and outposts in general are like a
bridge
outposts protect weaknesses that are
left behind the outpost and if you give
up the bishop
these pawns on a5 and c5 which looked
really good
are now incredibly weak okay sorry
that's a pretty out there analogy
but i really want to make this important
point you shouldn't have the default to
like take a piece when it's when a trade
is offered
okay so a new bridge was built and
that bridge did not go live so queen d5
bishop takes before a takes before
capturing toward the center keeping the
pawn
on c5 to pressure d4
thank you rook f28 improving the rook
and now a5 was the big mistake this was
the decisive mistake because
it leaves the knight unprotected and he
misses the tactic what should white have
done here probably just improved his own
position with rookies but i think white
is fine here
it's a it's a game maybe black is a
little bit
a little bit better but after a5 c4 the
knight gets caught on the crossfire the
move queen e2
would have been superior to queen d2 uh
the reason why is that here
we do not have the move c3 in fact the
queen is pinned
so at least white preserves relative
material balance um
black is still better though
so queen d2 queen v5 now c3 we win the
pawn and we get a
huge protected passer now spicy played
well here
but ultimately we trade rooks because
we're up a pun and we have a passer when
we have a pass pawn like this we want to
get the game into the end game
and now the key idea b5 why we want to
get the rook to a7 why we want to trade
rooks why do we want to trade rooks
as i just explained we want to simplify
because past spawns are most
important in the end game that's exactly
what we do
now we get the queen to b2 dislodging
the queen from c2
and now why didn't we play c2 could
somebody explain to me why this doesn't
just promote the pawn it actually does
but um this leads to unnecessary
complications
this is a good this is an important
point
so it's not knight d3 because then we
just win the night it's actually check
and notice that black's queen is all of
a sudden out of the game
that's like timor gorillaps going from
my game and all of a sudden
it's very i don't think it's possible to
avoid perpetual in fact in many cases
if you watch end games you can actually
allow black to promote
and i actually think white might almost
be winning here white has this huge
attack and black actually has no checks
despite the fact that he's got two
queens so be careful about assuming that
the game is over when you promoted a
second queen
be very careful about that sometimes
even with two queens the king is
relatively insulated against this
and black is actually losing here i've
confirmed it with a computer
so you know be careful about that that's
why we take on f2 so that this queen
could bring itself back to f6 take care
of the king first
and now we can with a single mind ah
spicy with 800 bits and we simply
promote 94 by the way
nice little detail of c2 then he goes
knight t3 stopping the plot
so knight e4 derails his knight from
c5 get it uh and if he had taken the
knight we go c2 and we win the game
okay moving right along 200 bits thank
you
moriyam gm we're playing a gm okay
now let's play the modern uh i've played
this i think once before i want to
showcase how to play
hyper modern openings now this is the
sort of cousin of the perk it often
transposes into the perk and he plays
bishop c4 okay
so uh in this position we of course want
to develop the knights
uh yeah what is wrong with this move
ladies and gentlemen
and maybe i should have done this
against celshan trusted myself
correct you know practice what i preach
thank you ladies and gentlemen for the
free pawn
no reason not to take it he just uh
auto-piloted it don't autopilot when
your opponent plays unusual openings now
very important to react accurately here
how should we react what are the
possibilities here there are several
good ways we can play d5 to cement the
knight
on the e4 square and i actually quite
like this move
okay we can build up a little pawn chain
or we can cover with the bishop but
let's build up the pawn chain
now what should we do here what would be
in the spirit
well actually okay so here's where a lot
of people would slip up
a lot of people would be tempted i think
to play bishop f5
but the problem with bishop f5 i called
it
is why does this very nasty move knight
to h4
okay and um that
knight attacks the bishop and the entire
construction threatens to topple over so
let's invite harry nelson pillsbury
and let's let mr pillsbury do some
talking this is the pillsbury knight
remember what i always say pawns are the
best defender of a piece
when a pawn defends a piece that piece
is very stable why can try to go f3 in
the future but guess what
white's already castled so a move like
f3 might end up in disaster do we take
the knight
do we have to do anything here at all
just castle just develop same spirit
okay now we have a very good move what
am i saying here i'm seeing the knight
this is a type
two undefended piece uh which means that
it's only protected by one piece so what
my brain immediately notices here is the
fact that the queen x-rays the knight
through the lens of the pawn
let's move that pawn out simultaneously
occupying the center
that's the great thing about the pill oh
thank you for the night okay this guy is
really not having his best day
he blunders the knight but already white
was basically lost
and that is the game okay well that was
a quickie
it won't take us long to analyze so
queen e2 here by the way
is is the main move um
as far as i know you you do need to
defend the pawn uh that is not a bad
idea
but uh our opponent yielded yield to
that part now the only really important
moment here was this position
i'm sure bishop f5 was fine but
uh i was a little bit scared of the move
knight h4 guys
what's the problem here with black why
is this even an issue well the problem
is
let's say we castle right he plays
knight takes f5
yeah and we have to get this very nasty
pawn structure you might argue well
isn't this a pillsbury knight well it is
but now we've given him like this h5
square for his queen no need to
to ruin our pawn structure like that so
knight h4 is not a big issue
um but f5 is a more stable way to defend
the knight in my opinion
so knight g5 we simply castle obviously
we don't take the knight that would
defeat the whole purpose
of putting it on e4 in fact that would
be very bad for black
and if he goes f3 uh we actually just
take on d4 with devastating consequences
to the king
the funny thing is if the king goes to
f1 do we actually have to move the
knight here what would what would be
black's best move
in other words borrowing from the game
what you guys should see here is the
fact that the rook is x-raying the king
which means that
the funny thing is he actually is not
threatening the night we can still go e5
as if nothing was going on because if he
takes he's literally going to get
checkmated in the center of the board
that's literally what's going to happen
so
this is a disaster he played c3 and now
e5 is a simple tactic
extending the attack on the knight if he
takes we take with the f-pawn to open
the f-file we have a brilliant pawn mass
and we're up upon
horrible position for roy but he at
least should have done this after bishop
takes c4 we of course also take with the
f pawn
we don't take with a d-pawn cause that
would also open up this diagonal
the h6 would be the same idea in spirit
but it wouldn't carry the
the benefit of opening up the center and
that's what's important about that move
is that
does that make sense guys
okay so
let me see here
okay any questions how about d5 instead
of d6
what if he tries to cement his knight on
e5 it's a pretty weak square well if he
tries to cement his knight on e5
we can we can assail it with knight d7
right
we have plenty of pieces that are
guarding that square that's a great
point
and we have to factor that when you play
a move like f5 you
absolutely have to factor in the fact
that you're weakening e5
right and um that's just something you
have to notice but
we notice it because we have plenty of
pieces that are defending that square
so type one undefended piece right type
one undefended piece
is a piece that is not defended by any
other pieces or pawns
a defended piece is a piece that is
defended by either
a pawn or more than one
pieces okay we call that he's defended
bishop on f4
would be a type one undefended piece
nothing is defending it
clear type two undefended piece a piece
that is only protected
by exactly one other piece and not a
pawn
right so for example here um
i'm looking bishop on g7 is type one
could you name a black piece that is a
type two undefended piece
i love el shawn he's great he's a very
very nice guy and very classy and
you know rook on h8 yes now
here's the thing guys not every night on
v8
this idea loses its meaning if you
indiscriminately kind of point to every
piece and think ah this piece is
important
you have to exercise your judgment in
terms of identifying
the type two undefended pieces that
might be vulnerable like the knight on
v8 is not vulnerable well
it could be but i would say the rook on
eight shade is less vulnerable than the
knight of the bishop right
uh the knight is made contact with the
by the bishop so by definition
or at least using our judgment we can
conclude
that there it's more likely that there's
going to be some sort of a tactic with
the knight
then with the rook um well orpheus well
that's that's where it gets into the
tricky bit right if you're aware
of the fact that you're making an
undefended piece that's already
part of the process toward not
blundering awareness is very important
in chess right
blunders often happen because precisely
because we are unaware
that a certain piece is vulnerable so
awareness will not always produce
total lack of blunders nobody can
eliminate blunders but it's important
let's move on